[Music]
now next up do you remember the reports
last month about china developing a new
hypersonic nuclear-enabled missile that
was able to circumnavigate the world and
strike it turns out we were told that
american intelligence were quite
surprised by how advanced the chinese
technology were because they were more
advanced than the americans themselves
in this week's magazine andrew coborn
cast some doubts on this arguing that
the west has got a little bit carried
away with how advanced china might be he
joins me now as does my colleague cindy
you
andrew um
why aren't you worried about this
because the chinese obviously do have
the technology so what's to say that
they have not actually overtaken america
and russia with this new hypersonic
glide technology that everybody is
trying to develop
well there's a number of reasons um
you know they used to say the pentagon
talk about uh weapons that don't work to
meet threats that don't exist
and this is a shining example of that um
there are inherent reasons why
a hypersonic missile which i should
quickly say simply means something that
travels at more than five times the
speed of sound
um
it's not a very sort of worthwhile
weapon of war because the whole
point is that it should
fly glide along it's boosted into orbit
by a
rocket
uh just like any space vehicle but then
is released at the just at the top of
the atmosphere
and
basically given an almighty shove by the
rocket and then
flies through the atmosphere toward its
target maneuvering using flying like an
airplane um as an airplane in fact
um
and the whole point of that is that
therefore you can't it's impossible to
track to know where it's going to be
with an ordinary ballistic missile
you know once it's set off and you can
see where it's going you know where it's
going to be and you can intercept it
theoretically
um and this gets around that that's
what's meant to be scary about it
except that
we don't have any defenses against
ballistic missiles anyway
um
you know they've been trying for years
they spent 200 million billion dollars
since ronald reagan unveiled the idea
back in 1983 and they still
have got almost nothing to show for it
they're still working out still spending
billions
so
you know there's nothing new there's no
new threat here
and by the way
i've been trying to reduce a complicated
technological thing to brief sentences
in
maneuvering through the atmosphere the
thing quickly loses energy i mean it's
you know it's like uh
you know
in the act of sort of
turning or diving or climbing it slows
down
so cindy if it's useless then why is the
chinese government spending so much
money on it
i think we have to look at where else in
the world is doing it because it's not
just the chinese and the americans it's
also the russians as andrew points out
in his article putin has made this um a
key military facet since 2018 and the
chinese are following this you know when
we
if you look at
supersonic nuclear missile if you search
that in a chinese search engine most of
the articles that come up about how
ahead the russians are so i do think we
have to take that into account that to
china great power competition isn't just
about america it's also about the other
big beasts in the world and fraser just
to go back to you on your point before
about chinese military capability being
better than the americans on new on
ballistic and cruise missiles they are
but just on that and the reason for that
is because of china's geography it's
surrounded by countries in a way that
america is not or countries potentially
that you might have um conflict with and
so it has concentrated on that part of
its capability in a way that america
doesn't have to so on that point it is
better than americans but that doesn't
mean the whole military as a whole is um
better than americans it still only
spends less than a third of the u.s
defense uh budget on its own defense
even though the army is much larger
andrew isn't that a decent point when
you look at the world's great defence
spenders china is pretty small i mean
your average native country is supposed
to spend two percent of gdp on defense
now britain does france more or less but
most of them don't but china is
something like 1.7 so this does not look
like a a country which is really
budgeting for for conflicts in the way
that we certainly saw we tend to see in
the build up to wars
well this is true and in fact um i think
it's the case they still spend more
on their internal security apparatus for
keeping the
chinese people under control the
people's arms armed police and a huge
apparatus of censorship and all the rest
they spend more on that than they do on
their external military so all this tub
thumping that we see in the press you
know with
like the hypersonic missiles we're
discussing you know should be seen in
that context that they see
it looks like they see a bigger threat
from their own people than they do from
they you know any external enemy but
what about the military buildup in the
taiwanese m coast there i mean that
can't be an internal threat i mean
that's right now is the number one focus
of american attention and the the
understanding in washington and in
london is that china if it wanted to
could make an assault in taiwan pretty
quickly doesn't need missiles for that
it just needs boats to go a few miles
over the sea and annex currently
sovereign territory
well you know it's very easy to once you
sort of
put that all that in one sentence it all
makes it sound quite easy but you know
they've got
you know we in 1944
we the allies
went to enormous i mean took an enormous
effort
to move um and then an invading army 20
miles
or across the channel
or slightly more than 20 miles but uh
but the chinese to go to taiwan is a
hundred miles um
they need more uh more than two
amphibious ships which is all they have
at the moment uh i mean amphibious
support ships um
they probably might need more than
uh two well i think they're heading for
four aircraft carriers uh i think one
they converted into a hotel but never
mind
i mean it's it's it's it's a really
it's just a very silly idea i mean that
they that they and they keep saying we
don't think we could do this um
you know it's worth
looking at what the chinese say about
themselves
uh in the chinese literature and they
keep sort of complaining that the troops
aren't properly trained
don't know how to use the weapons that
the whole thing's been disorganized they
haven't done a major exercise since i
think 2017
um
and as for these you know incursions
into taiwanese airspace that we read so
much about the press if you look at the
map of where the planes actually went
they basically go along
one side of this
self-declared air defense identification
zone which is not
national airspace and fly along it maybe
one plane a day sometimes many more but
i was the time one plane then go home
again it looks more like training
flights in fact the taiwanese chief of
staff said the other day that's what
they were
so cindy and how do you see this the
chinese people um seem to take
reasonable pride in the military china
still has military parades where the
latest weapons are put on put on display
here i mean do they regard military
spending as a waste of money or
something that an up-and-coming nation
needs in order to stake its claim to be
the kind of the power in the region that
certainly seems to be um as you've
written before this is what she wants he
wants to be the top dog in asia for that
he will need a military capable of
projecting if he chooses to do so
yeah fraser i think it is much more
about national pride and i think people
are happy to spend as much money um and
you know the the dynamics that andrew
picks out in this military
military-industrial complex that happens
in america happens in china too because
once you big up the threat coming from
places like america as a chinese person
you're going to want to defend yourself
from that or you want to protect your
territorial claims for example in the
south china sea or fraser you said
taiwan which i would argue that the
chinese do see as an internal problem um
as we know that they argue about that so
so for things like that either it's for
defense or for
securing your own interests in in its
near broad as it were um the chinese are
quite happy to spend money on that and
some of it is not though so the people's
liberation army has been undergoing
modernization some of it is not about
spending more it's just about spending
more cleverly it's about reorganizing
it's about spending less on the army
more in the navy more on the space force
that sort of rejecting which is
something that presidency has very much
been looking at but one thing that
they've been lacking still is this kind
of capability to have joint missions so
to take taiwan you need to have air sea
and land operating together and at the
moment the chinese are still not quite
there yet with that so you can see in
the curriculum in military academies
where they're still kind of figuring out
what is the right approach to teach uh
its students so yes on that joint
capability part no amount of money is
going to be able to fix that in the
short term
[Music]
you